-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
During a rally over
the weekend in Texas,
former president Trump said that
if he wins the 2024 election,
he will consider pardoning
the people charged with
participating in
the Capitol attack.
"In that case, I was there,"
said Ghislaine Maxwell.
During the same rally,
former president Trump
told supporters that, "In 2024,
we're going to take back
that beautiful, beautiful house
that happens to be white,
but it's not the one
you're thinking of."
In a new interview,
Maine Senator Susan Collins
criticized
President Biden for announcing
that he will nominate a
black woman to the Supreme Court
and said that he,
"Helped politicize
the entire nomination process."
Collins' comments have drawn
a stern rebuke from
the Black Republican Women
of Maine.
ESPN reported on Saturday that
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
quarterback Tom Brady
will retire after 22 seasons,
seven Super Bowl titles,
and -- oh, what do you know? --
zero field goals.
Well, guess he wasn't that
great after all.
Former White House adviser
Kellyanne Conway
announced last week that
she will release a memoir
in May called "Here's the Deal,"
which is also the name of
the bookstore bin
where you'll find it.
[ Laughter ]
Kid Rock announced last week --
Kid Rock news. Quiet down.
[ Laughter ]
Kid Rock announced last week
that he will not perform
at any venue that requires
coronavirus vaccines
or face masks.
Well, if anyone is going to
ignore the science,
it's a 51-year-old man
named Kid.
Tesla recently began selling an
in-car karaoke microphone
in China,
and that seems like trouble
considering how drunk
you have to be to do karaoke.
Today was
National Hot Chocolate Day.
Ugh! Well, she used to be.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a federal judge in Oklahoma
re-sentenced
Netflix's "Tiger King" star
Joe Exotic to 21 years
in prison last week.
Letting him out any sooner would
put the public at risk
for a third season.
Hard to follow hot chocolate.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!